so you know how sometimes when someone's
having a baby yeah they crave weird
foods okay you're gonna eat all the
weird ones I crave hi I'm Hannah I'm the
world's OKs mom and I am very pregnant
and along with pregnancy comes good old
pregnancy cravings the good the bad and
the ugly and in an attempt to
participate a little bit more in my
pregnancy my family asked to try all of
my pregnancy cravings with me we did it
it's done we tried it and here's how it
was first the rules what we ended up
doing was tracking all of my pregnancy
cravings for an entire month and each
time a craving struck my family would
shirt with me and it ended up being
seven cravings total I don't fully know
why people get pregnancy cravings I
think that sometimes it can indicate an
underlying issue sometimes it can
indicate a vitamin deficiency oftentimes
it's literally for no reason and makes
no sense I know that sometimes the
surplus of hormones can change the way
things taste but honestly some of the
things I've craved there's no good
reason for it now this was on a
voluntary basis I did not want anyone to
suffer permanent trauma from having to
try something so disgusting it was up to
the kids if they wanted to try it but my
husband had no choice because if I'm
pregnant he's pregnant and if I'm in
pain he's in pain and if I'm craving
something he's craving something too if
I've to do this he has to suffer a
little bit great day one of pregnancy
cravings I'm actually really excited for
this one so a little bit of backstory I
was at the grocery store and I saw this
like canned cheese and at the time it
sounded amazing I noticed this is a
recurring thing with all of my
pregnancies and it's craving foods that
I haven't actually tried like I'll see a
commercial and have a thought of how it
tastes and usually it's very satisfying
but it's this ongoing thing of me
craving something that I don't actually
know how it tastes
today
the mood just struck me and it sounded
amazing and I realized I have it because
I bought it a while ago early pregnant
Hannah is thinking about late pregnant
Hannah this is gonna be the first thing
that the kids try they've never tasted
this in their life I've never tasted
this in my life I just remember it from
a goofy movie and it looks delicious so
we're going with it I did not feel like
I wanted it on a cracker
I wanted it on something else kind of
salty or like cold does that make sense
hey boys I have a surprise for you when
I brought out the spray cheese the kids
were actually really excited to try it
yay so you know how sometimes when
someone's having a baby yeah they crave
weird foods okay you're gonna eat all
the weird ones I crave this first course
weightless all cheers this first course
I did we love olives and tomatoes with
spray cheese okay ready hold on come
here
cheers Cheers like this okay look at me
what do you think you think I poison
them honestly they're so dramatic it
wasn't that bad babies it takes like dog
food you're like the cheese or it looks
like he's heat let's see how this tastes
geez oh man oh that is good
hmm come here with that cheese we try it
tomato cheese so once my kids got over
the trauma of having to try it on an
olive which again didn't think it was a
big deal they wanted to give it a second
chance and asked me to spray it directly
in their mouths
this stuff is the business Oh
oh that is so good it's 8:00 in the
morning and I am craving refried beans
cheese and jalapenos I'm gonna make a
birthday or birthday oh my god what's
wrong with me I have such bad pregnancy
brain today I have for you chocolate
pumpkin pancakes
Oh refried beans and cheese this is what
I felt like eating this I did not make
my children eat any jalapenos I am NOT
that mean give it a try
mama look it do you like it Abby no
route together Jackson are you pregnant
Matt has to eat some jalapenos you have
about a third as many my stomach can't
take it - I say in the morning you love
it you can eat a whole can of it was it
good yeah let's get shoo jalapenos on
there mmm
that was a win it will about a sweet you
have a little bit savory you get a
little spicy see not every craving is
disgusting okay it is me back with
another craving just hit as we were
walking out the door I am craving a
french fries and mayonnaise basically
during my pregnancy I traveled to Europe
twice and in Europe
I noticed especially in the Netherlands
there are a lot of french fries spots
and the condiment that everybody uses
to dip their french fries in is
mayonnaise I think it'll be good I don't
think anybody will mind this craving
very excited I didn't know what to
expect all I know is it looked really
nice what do you think kind of good hey
Jackson come try this okay give it a try
you don't like it oh you've got for sure
sounds good right that's pretty good
it's really good mmm
that was a good idea I'm proud of myself
this is just what I wanted
there's nothing better than craving
something and like wanting a taste of
something and then you achieve it moving
on to craving number four this was a fun
one I wanted some pizza so I got some
pizza the kids are super stoked but
there's a catch I looked in the fridge
when I was going to make like some
veggies chopped veggies or salad excuse
me
okay finish yeah I craved pizza topped
with sauerkraut now let me explain the
way that a lot of cravings come to be is
I'll be holding of food and looking at
another and be like huh okay I will
defend this until the day I die
sauerkraut is tangy it is crunchy it is
nice and cold and it's just it's a great
texture to pair it along with something
soft like pizza maybe I will watch this
back when I'm not pregnant and be like
what happened to me
are you excited to try it
[Music]
are you excited to try it what it can
help no oh wait look who doesn't have
his oh we better wait growing boy needs
needs his keep
Oh let's get extra for the big guy okay
pretty good oh don't even worry about it
you're gonna love it alright who goes
first okay to do it honey
how's it taste terrible
the general consensus was extremely
negative like extremely negative like a
little bit harsh and mean I'm gonna be
honest you just copied your brother what
do you think you don't like it okay let
the ones get a relic dalts opinion here
tell me it's not so bad
Matt's a guy who's very much like if
it's food I'll eat it mm-hmm what
sauerkraut does there
get a real verdict on this mmm oh this
is good it's tangy oh I will eat this
even when I'm not pregnant
I feel like no one will be able to look
at me the same after after this whole
experience you're really getting the
Hannah uncensored right now it's a new
day I got new hair and I got a new
creaming look at how big I've gotten
that guy's pretty hungry right now and
you know what he wants you want potato
chips with cottage cheese scooped up
into them okay Wyatt first stuff get you
good scoop oh snap look at me open your
mouth
so you don't still uh-huh one of them
that yes do you like it why it loves
cottage cheese and he loves chips this
is actually something I will probably
continue to feed Wyatt because we all
know how picky he can be Wow this is a
surprise
to say the least if you thinks it's fun
dip in a chip in it go forth and have
fun alright hold on let me get a nice
nice scoop for you Jackson fun fact he
hates cottage cheese I'm surprised I
even got him to take a bite you like it
right no my turn I've been waiting all
day for this I love me some cottage
cheese I love me some potato chips
there's your masterpiece so you thought
the cravings were getting normal didn't
you no you were wrong because craving
number six I don't know I'm going to say
it
mmm so here I have an apple simple apple
not bad what am I gonna do with this
Apple I'm sure you're wondering well I
tell you what I'm gonna dip it in ranch
dressing I just wanted to see what would
happen you know never wanted to hurt
anybody never wanted to do any harm I
just wanted to see what would happen if
I dipped an apple in some ranch get a
nice big scoop of ranch on there wow you
like it
okay Jackson you try it
oh gosh you had a lot of ranch give it a
chance Jackson it's not something that
should happen and I think it was very
unnatural but I didn't mind it this is
fine
did I Charlotte I think I've actually
tried this before you have I felt very
judged unnecessarily by my family when I
made it I didn't think they were being
fair there I said it
tonight craving is being cooked as we
speak got a little something to meet
laughing got a little something in the
pots
you've heard of spaghetti tacos you know
that my family eats them we love our
spaghetti tacos we love our spaghetti we
love eating it in different shapes and
forms and so it just struck me one day
during this pregnancy we've had
spaghetti so many different ways but
we've never had it sandwiched between
two pieces of garlic bread
look at this masterpiece Oh spaghetti
garlic bread Sam watch thinking about it
right now makes me want to cry it's so
good
good huh I mean this was the biggest mom
win I've had in a very long time you
like it oh yeah nice this bread is good
since we've tried it the kids have
continued to ask for it almost daily
because it is that delicious
oh no okay
oh good all of us like it
all right success I'm one happy pregnant
lady right now this started out as kind
of just a funny experiment but what I
realized it did ultimately was it
involved my kids in my pregnancy which
because it's something so personal
that's happening just to me I forget
that the kids want to be a part of
what's happening with their baby brother
and it's not just when he's born they
want to be a part of the pregnancy and
included in this time and they had a
really good time so I would highly
recommend trying this just maybe don't
eat can spray cheese on all so that's
what I got for today I'm Hannah and if
you've been pregnant and had any weird
cravings leave those in the comments I
want to see everyone else's cravings or
if you know anyone who had any weird
pregnancy cravings let me know in the
comments as well now if you'll please
excuse me I have to satisfy my current
craving right now which is a straight up
whipped cream until next time
oh this is hard
[Music]
you wanna try this why